oh
[Musique]
on
le
il
[Musique]
je m'appelle olivier rocheau j'ai 49 ans
j'ai fondé la société otx en février
2019 pourront bientôt deux ans on est
installé dans les locaux de ski cube à
guyancourt
orth x c'est une société qui développe
des solutions numériques pour l'usagé
des agriculteurs
[Musique]
à grigny qui c'est une solution qui
s'appuie sur un équipement embarqué dans
la cabine des tracteurs des engins
motorisés
associé à un équipement électronique
posées sur les outils qui vont permettre
de déterminer automatiquement la nature
des activités réalisées par
l'agriculteur les parcelles sur lequel
ils le font et les matériels qu'ils
utilisent de cette manière on va
déterminer sans aucune saisie ce que
l'agriculteur est en train de faire de
façon à répondre à une obligation de
traçabilité notre part à green it y va
interagir avec le chauffeur avec
l'agriculteur dans sa cabine directement
quand il aura besoin d'informations
complémentaires sur cette activité à
green it i c'est que l'agriculteur est
en train de sonner
il sait dans quelle parcelle et il va
demander à l'agriculteur la nature la
mer était qu'est en train de sonner
[Musique]
notre actualitté c'est le lancement
commercial de la résolution ont l'âme
tests sur le terrain maintenant depuis
juin 2019
donc elle était mise à l'épreuve pendant
plus d'un an ça nous a permis de la
mettre au point de la compléter de voir
quels étaient les attentes des
agriculteurs et on a terminé cette phase
de prototypage de réalisation pour
aboutir à une solution commerciale qui
est maintenant disponible depuis le mois
d'octobre avec une première
commercialisation au travers du
groupement ou avec lequel on a signé
donc le groupe noria ben qui propose
aujourd'hui en avant-première à green it
i à ses adhérents
[Musique]